français popineau secrétaire général et
porte parole du snuipp fsu le premier
syndicat des enseignants du primaire
bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous
reprise de l'école le 11 mai on avait lu
dans la presse dans certaines presses
voilà à l'éventualité de pousser
jusqu'en septembre vous quelle est votre
réaction ce soir de se dire il faut
encore obtenir un mois ont plutôt le
soulagement que ça reprenne néanmoins
quand même le 11 mai
ni la ville où j'allais dire parce que
bien sûr nous avons le souhait de
reprendre l'école avant l'été parce que
c'est important pour les enfants et les
enfants qui ne vivent pas le confinement
tous de la même manière et c'est
important de qu'il y ait une reprise de
l'école en revanche le 11 mai dans le
discours du président il ya des
contradictions parce que si le 11 mai on
ne peut pas ouvrir les cinémas on ne
peut pas ouvrir les restaurants
comment pourrions nous ouvrir une école
où on sait que c'est un lieu de
transmission quand même très actif donc
effectivement ça ça nous interroge on se
demande s'il n'ya pas un petit peu
d'imprudence là dedans bien sûr il faut
que les gens reprennent le travail nous
en sommes absolument conscient
nous avons nous aussi envie de retrouver
nos élèves c'est pas le sujet mais il
faut le faire en étant sûr sur le plan
sanitaire
il s'agit pas de reprendre l'école et
ensuite de se retrouver confiné quinze
jours plus tard donc là on a une vraie
inquiétude
et puis effectivement il faut travailler
à cette progressivité
ça veut dire que on ne pourra pas
revenir sereinement en classe tous
ensemble il faudra envisager des demies
groupe voire des tiers de groupe il
faudra des récréations échelonnée et
puis il faut effectivement que tout le
personnel adultes autour enseignants
mais aussi personnel de cantine zem et
caetera et les protections nécessaires
or nous savons que nous courons après
les protections à c'est vraiment devenu
très compliqué donc il va falloir que
nous ayons beaucoup de détails sur cette
histoire dure 11 mai et que nous soyons
sûrs que d'un point de vue sanitaire
personne ne prend de risques parce que
si les enfants reviennent à l'école vous
savez c'est très difficile les gestes
barrière chez les enfants jeunes
donc b ils se touchent ils jouent
ensemble bien sûr et puis ensuite il
rentre à la maison et puis
éventuellement ils vont s'élever papier
ou mamie donc vous imaginez là la chaîne
de transmission qui peut encore avoir
lieu si le trail et 11 mais nous ne
pouvons pas ouvrir les restaurants nous
ne comprenons pas que nous pouvons
ouvrir les écoles tout en disant qu'il
sera important à un moment donné de
reprendre la classe bien évidemment et
c'est vrai pour les inégalités et
faisons le en étant sûr de ne mettre
aucun personnel en danger et que la
santé de tous sera toujours protégé
c'est ça ma priorité avant la pédagogie
avant l'économie
il faut maintenir la santé de chacun on
entend effectivement votre inquiétude en
tant que représentant de décence aignan
pensez vous qu emmanuel macron en tout
cas son ministre jean michel blanquer a
peut-être consulté les syndicats les
enseignants avant de prendre cette
décision parce qu'il arrive que
peut-être je vous pose d'ailleurs la
question ce soir de se heurter à un
refus tout simplement de la part des
enseignants à à retourner travailler
le 11 mai ce que vous iriez jusque là
justement à une forme de droit de
retrait tout simplement de peur que le
virieu le virus circule c'est le
sanitaire qui nous guide un sais pas
c'est pas l'avis des uns ou des autres
c'est le sanitaire qui nous guide qu'en
10e le ms candy l'inserm
voilà c'est ça qui est important si on
nous dit qu'il n'y a aucun risque pour
la santé
je crois que tous les enseignants seront
ravis de reprendre le chemin de l'école
et les enfants aussi
et c'est important pour tout le monde
mais ce dont on veut avoir l'assurance
c'est effectivement est ce qu'il n'ya
pas de mise en danger de la santé
hélas dans ce discours contradictoires
on a des doutes alors sur le plan du
travail oui nous travaillons avec le
ministère sur une reprise éventuelle
c'est un scénario que nous avions
envisagé que nous continuons à
travailler sur une reprise effectivement
avant l'été le scénario demi mais
n'avait pas été produit jusqu alors nous
étions plutôt sur un scénario en juin
avec comme je vous le disais
je veux des étapes des devis groupes ou
des tiers de groupe avec une protection
évidemment des adultes et des enfants
ça fait la française pauline au pardon
vous pouvez vous avez vous êtes étonné
ce soir vous en tant qu'enseignant vous
disiez on était plutôt sur un scénario
de juin vous vous attendiez pas cette
décision d' emmanuel macron de reprise
des cols dont 11 mai non mais je le
redis nous la population ne sait pas de
de l'eau mais ça nous pose pas de
problème en soi ce qui est étonnant dans
le discours c'est que le 11 mai on note
bien que la reprise des collectifs les
événements de l'été sont annulés donc
tous les collectifs sont annulés souffre
l'école c'est ça qui nous interroge
aujourd'hui et on se demande si derrière
ça il n'y a pas de l'imprudence alors
ici pardonnez moi même coupé on a bien
compris justement mais emmanuel macron
mettait en avant
effectivement pas des raisons sanitaires
et il a bien dit qu'il y aurait besoin
d'aménagements de règles particulières
pour protéger notamment les professeurs
mais il a mis en avant les inégalités
peut-être voir des élèves plus
défavorisés que d'autres pour qui
c'était extrêmement compliqué de ne pas
les allées à l'école quelle est votre
réaction par rapport à cet argument bien
sûr nous avons eu aussi évoqué les
inégalités depuis longtemps à nous
savons qu on a une école qui est
inégalitaire les inégalités existent la
crise les a seulement mise en lumière
mais les inégalités malheureusement elle
existe ce sont des inégalités souvent au
social culturel etc paiera donc elles
sont à prendre en compte par l'école
c'est bien ce que nous réclamons depuis
depuis longtemps et lorsque c'est
effectivement il y aura une reprise pour
qu'elle soit sereine
il faudra aussi que nous soyons entouré
de psychologues sans doute de médecins
d'infirmières parce qu'il y aura des
enfants qui auront vécu le confinement
d'une manière extrêmement difficile et
avant de reprendre l'école avant de
reprendre les apprentissages
ils devront se réparer donc il va
falloir que nous ayons des personnels
avec nous pour nous et des assistantes
sociales infirmières psychologues
enseignants spécialisés il faudra que
l'école soit entouré pour pouvoir aider
tous ces enfants c'est très important ce
n'est pas parce que l'école va reprendre
que les problèmes seront réglés il y
aura des traumatismes y compris liés à
la perte des éléments de la famille une
dernière petite question rapidement
enseignante vous êtes inquiète par
rapport au programme à ce que vous aurez
le temps de rattraper ce programme après
des semaines de perdues
l'erreur serait effectivement de faire
la course programme sur le dernier mois
qui nous resterait au d'apprentissage
serait une erreur ce temps là va être un
temps où on va se retrouver où on va
comme je le disais panser des blessures
où on va se remettre à niveau
il faut envisager que cette année
effectivement ça s'est arrêté le 13 mars
au soir et on reprendra la classe au
moment où elle s'est arrêtée sur les
programmes des années suivantes
aucun enfant ne sera pénalisé mais il
faudra effectivement revoir comment on
réajuste les programmes dans les années
qui viennent pour effectivement
rattraper ce moment où l'école aura été
mis en sommeil
c'est évident qu'on le fera
progressivement mais on peut garantir
que la scolarité de l'enfant ne s'en
ressentira pas il y aura des mois de
retard mais ça se comblera et on ne le
verra plus d'ici quelques temps il faut
rassurer tout le monde à ce niveau là
mais mais le travail sera fait les
enseignants sauront comment réajuster
les programmes pour que tout se fasse
tranquillement et pour que tous les
enfants et tout ce qu'il faut pour
réussir
merci beaucoup français tape au pineau
secrétaire général porte parole du
snuipp fsu d'avoir été avec nous